look we are still hopeful that President
Obama will make will keep the promises
you made as candidate but there are some
early signs that were not going down the
right path he told us we would reject
the military commissions act and yet now
he's talking about retaining the
military commissions as a way to deal
with some of the detainees at Guantanamo
huge mistake you can't fix that you got
to scrap it got throw these individuals
into established courts you can't tinker
at the edges with the military
commissions act he told us he would
restore the rule of law and yet now he's
telling us that he wants to enact a
preventive detention regime which is
essentially a nice word for holding
people indefinitely without charge or
trial can't do that that's not the
American Way we've never allowed that
for hundreds of years America cannot
hold people who we are suspicious of
merely because they may pose a threat if
you can't prove it you can't take away
someone's fundamental right to Liberty
and do so in a way that doesn't convict
the person in a court of law that's just
it's it's anathem up to the Fourth and
Fifth Amendment's you have the president
telling us that he was going to make
good on some core issues around gay
rights and questions around equality in
America that seemed to be very slow in
coming you know the saying that i'm
going to give gay lesbian people their
full rights as individuals and yet
defending the Defense of Marriage Act it
doesn't compute frankly if those
promises were made you can't defend the
Defense of Marriage Act you can't drag
your feet on Don't Ask Don't Tell I
think one of the concerns we have is
that the president is saying I have all
these other issues that are on the front
burner the economy the wars health care
we all get that we're all Americans we
all care about people dying in wars we
all care about health care we all care
about the economy but frankly we can't
wait to fix all those problems before we
get to some really important problems
that he he and he alone and His garment
can fix you can't sequence in a way
that's going to you're going to fix the
economy of the health care and the
environment and the wars and then we'll
turn to gay people and administration of
justice and detainees and torture and
abuse
it's not we're not we're never going to
get to and frankly everyone knows that
it's the first 18 months of
administration that will allow him the
room and the latitude to make decisive
breaks with the past and unless we
occupy that initial window with some
really bold decisive actions we'll find
ourselves in a new reelection campaign
we'll find ourselves with pundits on
both sides saying defer these issues
further until the second term and
frankly a dream deferred is a dream lost
and frankly time is on a luxury we can
afford ourselves when it comes to core
issues like due process and human rights
and equality and that's why we're hoping
about putting his feet to the fire on
these issues that he'll get the
political will to do the right thing